[Music]
it's et's social study your quick look
at what the Stars are posting online
I just feel good and I think that when
you feel good it gives you good energy
good vibes and that makes you look good
no denying Christie Brinkley is a total
knockout check out this glam gown she
rocked at the vibes by Sports
Illustrated bash in Houston showing off
tons of leg in this shot with Kate Upton
and Aly Raisman hello to Lisa Rinna who
went completely nude on Instagram she
candidly wrote I'm 53 0 given I took you
out of my trailer to my place to my name
I have no more questions I have no more
questions they do Josh GAD wants answers
on the upcoming Star Wars the last Jedi
film so he enlisted some major celebs to
grill star Daisy Ridley including Chris
Pratt Bryce Dallas Howard Penelope Cruz
and JJ Abrams
does Luke finally get to see any lions
in Episode eight please tell me Daisy
love is in the air for actor Colton
Haynes he confirmed his relationship
with floral designer Jeff Latham and
it's all fun and games when it comes to
celebrity babies here's Penelope Disick
with her cousin Northwest at a birthday
party
total meme material Chrissy Teigen and
John Legend little girl Luna had fun at
the aquarium and NBA all-star game and
Peta Murgatroyd blogged about the
meaning behind her son shiz name it
means gift in Hebrew it's really good
yeah
you